judiciaire en pleine enquête de
voisinage à la route ou à volga plage à
peine à 100 mètres de l'endroit où un
homme d'une trentaine d'années a été tué
hier soir son corps présentait près
d'une vingtaine d'impacts de balles et
une grosse quantité de drogue a été
retrouvé sur lui une histoire qui fait
parler les habitants du quartier j'ai
entendu des rafales et 7 juin
il ya des problèmes qui se passe alors
le gars ça fait un petit moment
bon je sais pas si c'est des gains ou
quoi que ce soit mais bon on est d'une
manière maintenant on voit ça fait
depuis
pendant les vacances il ya cette
histoire de cette lucien mais je pense
pas que tout ce qui se passe au 90e 6
discussions aussi je pense pas non plus
mais il faut pas épargné donc le
problème moi c'est ce que je me demande
pourquoi que les autorités la loi il ne
fait pas l'autre avec qui j'ai déjà
perdu au moins sept frangins ses poteaux
qui sont déjà partis à ces jeunes et
tout ça lassé des familles en pleurs
étaient des amis en pnc dit c'est tout
sauf que quand mais voilà quoi et puis
parce que c'est comme ça que ça continue
on doit rester là quoi l'état la loi la
loi la loi idées ou là ils sont si on
regarde ce qui se passe
il s'agit pas selon moi deux faits
divers s'agit de deux chiens qui se
passe quand il n'y a personne de qui ce
passe tabac la nuit et pour toujours les
mêmes raisons donc ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui est passé d'un quartier ce
n'est pas une sécurité qui interdisent
sont pas des gens disent pas dans le
quartier
il s'agit de frais bien circonscrit dans
un domaine un public particulier en
clair à mots couverts on nous parle de
trafic de stupéfiants et de guerre entre
trafiquants sainte luciens et
martiniquais chaque camp faisant des
victimes dans l'outil la houle affaires
se compliquent c'est que les simples
lucien sont le plus souvent hébergés
chez d'autres habitants de volga plage
créant une atmosphère de plus en plus
tendu dans le quartier c'est bon ça sur
le moins de
un de ses enfants de déclencheur c'est
pour ça parce qu'à des lignes et ils
sont plus loin c'est clair c'est un
sentiment de crainte d'une fois le soin
au tabac tabra tout avec des si dans la
rue tu vois sachant que ces choses que
tu pour rester chez toi
mais entre nous comme je vous dis on vit
la martinique c'est un beau pays
st baudille on à la plage on a le soleil
on a tous on est bien ici mais qui reste
ici vous voyez pas les jeunes qui
partent chaque année vous faites pas des
études sur les dépenses you personne ne
reste ici mais ici ça gâche la vie c'est
soit là c'est sûr la prison sur l'amo
volga plage un quartier faut y aller à
deux visages d'un côté celui des
associations et des habitants solidaires
de l'autre celui d'une délinquance qui
s'aggrave
inexorablement